>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Hello, my name is Steven
Winnick, I'm a folklorist here
at the American Folklife Center at
the Library of Congress and I'm here
with Carmen Agra Deedy
and Karla Campillo-Soto
but I will let them say
their own names actually just
so we get the proper
pronunciation so.
>> Carmen Agra Deedy.
>> Karla Campillo-Soto.
>> And both of these wonderful
women are storytellers
and gave us a presentation of
their stories earlier today
and we're going to
talk a little bit now
about storytelling
and their careers.
So, and they have different
backgrounds,
both obviously are Spanish-speaking
but Carmen is of Cuban background
and Karla is of Mexican background.
So we're going to start
by asking for a little bit
of Carmen's background
and to ask the question,
do you have any memories
of Cuba at all
and when did you come
to this country?
How old were you?
>> Yeah, I was three.
I do have some very visceral
memories meaning the brine
in the air because we lived in
Havana so my window faced the sea
so it would you know the sea
breeze would come in at night.
And I tell a story about that memory
in particular called [foreign
language spoken] "The Peanut Man"
and he was the fellow who is
very iconic in Cuban stories
and he tells everyone as he
goes through the city he sings
because he doesn't tell, he actually
sings [foreign language spoken].
And there are folkloric
songs about him
and that particular story I guess
for me is the strongest
memory I have of Cuba
because I suppose it's
so ethereal in a way.
I mean his voice was like this
red, velvet ribbon that wound
through the city at night and then
you would hear the [clicking sound
with voice] and he and the mule
would come through and I would look
down from my window and those were
my memories, that and some memories
of my grandmother that
are very faint.
>> And then so you came
to the United States?
>> I came to the U.S.
when I was three.
We went via Mexico and we were there
for, we left in December of '63
and if you will remember
there was a little tension
in the world at that time.
We then came to the U.S. in February
of '64 and did not stay in Miami.
We ended up in a little southern
town in Georgia, Decatur.
>> Yeah, so what was it like growing
up in Decatur as a Cuban person?
>> Oh my goodness, well,
yeah those stories,
I've been telling those for,
it took a while to tell those.
They actually became a, they
became a sort of compendium
of stories called "Growing Up
Cuban in Decatur, Georgia".
Yeah, it was.
Everything is new.
When you're a refugee or an
immigrant because those are defined
by the reasons you
left, everything is new.
I mean everything is different.
Everything is strange.
And those first years to me
were more about acclimation.
It was cold.
You know how it was, it was cold.
I was a child who had
grown up in the Caribbean
and now there was something called
[foreign language spoken] winter,
and so gone were sandals
year-round of course
and the peanut man didn't sing
because my father had taped
up the windows with duct
tape to keep out the cold.
Now it was actually, it was many
years before I realized there was no
peanut man.
I thought it was because
we had to keep plastic
on our windows in the
winter you know.
>> Right.
>> It was.
It was a journey that
feels unfinished.
>> Yeah and you said in your stories
that you did experience some sort
of casual racism or
xenophobia as a child.
>> Well I mean casual
and sometimes overt but
and it's not that I play it down.
I mean I tell stories that
occasionally, that includes some
of those sort of dissonant moments.
But, I found so many good
people and when it was time
to tell the stories
publically I used to tell them
on "All Things Considered" on NPR.
It was a conscious choice to
tell the heroic stories rather
than to immortalize the villains.
Who do you wish to remember?
And you know in ancient
Egypt when they wanted
to forget a pharaoh they'd just
scrub their names right off the
stelae [phonetic].
So although I tell some of
those stories they were,
they were the lessor in
frequency but they were also,
and they were painful to tell.
But then there are those people,
the ones who go beyond their birth
and their own prejudice
and do not think
that we did not have
our own prejudice.
We did, you know.
The first time I brought an
American boy home my mother was just
horrified because it
might stick [laughter].
I like real stories as I
notice Karla [inaudible].
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah and that's something that
we talked about a little bit too,
the sort of different kinds
of stories that you might tell
as a storyteller and that
your tendency is to focus
on home stories, family stories.
How did that develop?
>> It's so cultural for us, you
know the, everything begins at home.
And the most tragic story
you could ever read, write,
sing about would be about
the child that has no home.
And a child that has no home in our
culture, the village takes him in.
I mean you should.
And so it seems like for
us all stories lead home
but if you're a refugee that loss
of home means you know, at 55,
self-knowledge is excruciating.
Inevitably my stories
lead back to home.
>> And now Karla, your background is
somewhat different because you grew
up in Mexico and then
came here as an adult?
>> Yeah, I was actually an adult and
I was recruited by a school district
to come and teach in
the United States so.
But what she's talking about does
not change regardless of the age.
It's still a little bit scary
because you don't know what
you're facing and at least
where you grew up it's different.
It's just, it's you.
It embraces you.
And she was talking about
like don't fool yourself,
there's still a little
bit of racism.
When you leave to go to
another country your friends,
your family in Mexico they make sure
that you remember every single
time when you go back there.
They joke and they don't
really mean it but it's there.
And you never feel more Mexican
or more Cuban than when you're not
in Mexico, it's just the way it is.
>> Right.
>> It's in you, yeah.
>> The straddling of two, you know
I see it in the children a lot when,
we both work with children.
>> Yeah.
>> They are the interpreters whether
they're among refugee children
or they are Mexican-American
children
or they're Nicaraguan, Cuban.
It doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter if.
They're the ones who have
to interpret the world
for their family and conversely.
>> The family to the world, yeah.
>> Right, yeah.
>> It's not only the, don't
you find this amazing?
It's not only the language
that they're translating.
>> The language is the least.
>> But they're translating also.
>> The culture.
>> Their understanding of this
world and how it translates
into our world, they
just [multiple speakers].
>> And both sides are
suspicious of the other.
And there you are on
that strange [inaudible].
I've been working on this
story, I haven't told you about,
but in it I talk about
meeting this boy on moving day.
And we moved frequently
because of, I mean it was money.
We'd stay in a place that.
The next year the rent would go up,
we'd move again two blocks down.
But we moved into brand new
apartments and usually we moved
into very depressing places you
know and this place was like new
and the paint was new and
there was fresh carpeting
and my mother was just
out of her skin.
And she was singing.
Who knew the woman could sing?
And on that day I meet a
boy and as I'm running out,
tearing down the hallway,
the exterior hallway.
These were not fancy
apartments but they were new.
And as we'd run into one
another is this, clearly this,
you know southern boy with this, I
could see these extraordinary eyes
that looked like, what's that
stuff you use in the winter,
like antifreeze, you
know that pale blue.
I mean look how dark
our eyes are right?
And the first thing
he asked me is where,
if I'm the new, are
you the new people?
Are you all Number 8?
The apartment Number 8,
are you all Number 8?
And I say yes and the next thing
I say without even thinking
that this might be weird,
I say do you want to come
and watch my mother
burn the bathtub?
And of course he's a
southern kid, the first thing,
his [inaudible] response is,
oh you bet I would baby girl,
you bet I would because he doesn't
have an idea what this means.
But see children tend to
cross the cultural boundaries.
>> Yeah.
>> Because when you say
something that crazy,
by the way my mother
was a germaphobe.
Her grandmother and sister
died of typhoid in the 30s
so she would burn the
ceramic bathtub with alcohol
and a lit match would last
30 seconds and by the way
that bathtub, fiberglass.
>> Oh, oh.
>> Great story, but in any event
it's that translating and the fact
that the younger children
when you're growing up,
some could be cruel but a lot of
them are outwardly open and curious.
>> Yes, yes.
>> That's easier.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> So let's talk about when
you each sort of realized
that you had a gift
for storytelling.
How did that come about?
>> I never did [laughter].
>> Oh get out.
>> I never did.
I had to be told.
>> And who was it that
told you first?
Was it?
>> Yeah.
>> No, you had to have known.
I'm sure your family
has told you things,
you just didn't want to hear it.
>> Well, they told me
I would never shut up
but that's [laughter] different.
>> Well, see there you go.
>> Yeah.
>> Well my.
But that's because, in
most families this is not.
This is not endemic to
the Latin experience.
Most families, even families
who tend to be quieter,
families [inaudible] don't have
as much narrative in daily life.
>> Right.
>> Have occasionally one generation
or another a family
storyteller crops up.
It's a person that keeps track
of the different stories
and tells them best.
And during family reunions
you know it's the person
who everyone says, oh
no, no, no tell them.
Tell them, no, no not you.
Let him tell or let her tell.
>> Right.
>> Whether Karla knew
or not when we met
in five seconds I knew this woman
was just so, such a natural.
It just came out of every pore.
I mean she could take the
most quotidian experience
and it would become fabulous, it
was no longer an everyday, dull,
boring you know trip
to the grocery store.
>> And to be honest with you I'm
not the storyteller at my house.
The storyteller at my house is
my mother and all I do is just,
I am her, but she does
it so much better.
>> Well, but see she's in training.
My mother is gone.
>> Right, right.
>> In her family.
>> Right, sure and how about you?
I mean you must have realized
at some point you were?
>> When I first told my parents
because I was writing
children's books first
and then I started telling
stories to the children,
folktales because they were easy.
They were already pre-digested.
You just had to figure out how
to tell them but the beginning,
middle, and end was all there.
And then I started telling
a few family stories,
very cautiously putting
my toe into that sort
of pond of personal narrative.
And my sister had the genius idea
of, you know to invite my parents
and my father laughed
through the whole story
at that particular event.
It was the Atlanta History
Center as a matter of fact.
My mother, nothing,
nothing and I walked
up to her after and I said, okay?
They were [inaudible]?
You know, what did you think?
Did you like it, do you like?
It was not bad.
I don't recognize any of the
people in your stories but she was
of course the main character in
the story, the main character.
I would say for me the
stories started very painfully
because I was a listener most
of my life, not a storyteller
and I did not realize for many
years that had been the beginning.
That had been the true gift.
I was not gifted [inaudible]
with this, with a silver tongue.
I was given the gift of being a
sort of skittish kid that would stay
around the edges of
conversations and listen and grew
to so love the oral word, the
unspooling of that thread of story.
I couldn't get away.
I couldn't walk away if
it was in the middle.
I'd rather take a beating than
have to have been interrupted.
And when I first started
telling them I was, oh God.
I remember many humiliations so bad
but my father told me when I was
about to give up, he said
why do you want to do this?
And I said oh my God,
because I love it.
I could sit in a bus
station next to some old guy
and just ask him questions
and listen all day, pop.
And he said why do you
want to tell stories
and I said because I love stories.
I actually love telling
them but I'm not, I'm bad.
I mean I don't.
I get things mixed up,
their sequence and I.
And he's [inaudible] I understand.
I understand.
And he's got the answer because
he's like Yoda and he said,
you were born with a
great love for a thing
and you believed you were also
going to be born with skill.
I thought damn and this today
is called craft and years later,
fast forward like five
years ago I was reading
because [inaudible] mentioned
this somewhere "The Parliament
of Fowls" Chaucer's, oh it was a
few people or familiarize or under,
you know connect with him.
They think of the "Canterbury Tales"
and he says this beautiful line
and it says this for you, "The
life so short, the craft so long
to learn" and I kept that with me
when, even now when I get frustrated
because every new story
is like starting over.
>> Now you.
>> I will tell you this and
I apologize for interrupting.
The very first time I did a story.
>> That was a very American, you
just apologized for interrupting.
>> [Inaudible] I've
been trained well.
It was hard for me,
it was hard but I did.
See in my family, it's
just a competition.
>> All of us yes.
>> Whoever snatches the word first
but when I did my first, very,
very first storytelling it
was the worst thing ever.
I just, I was.
I wanted to quit.
So of course I picked up the
phone and I called her and said,
ah, this is was horrible.
And say what, she said,
well what did you expect?
You want to do it because
you like it.
Did you think this
was going to be easy?
And that stopped the
thing, so I kept doing it.
>> So the wisdom went from your
father and through you and?
>> I love that man, [multiple
speakers] don't you love him?
I love him.
>> But with school children
[inaudible] with them writing.
It's the same thing.
I thought this is a craft.
Do you know what that means?
That means you go back to the forge
and the anvil and the hammer again
and again and again and you
hate what you have hammered out.
And you go to bed and you're
so angry with yourself
and you hate the fire and you're
sick of the metal that cuts you
and the fire that burns you
and then one day you go back
and something happens.
And you went ah, beautiful
and now you want to figure
out how you did it
so you can do again.
>> [Multiple speakers]
I know you know.
I know you know [multiple speakers].
>> That is the hardest part.
>> And to you young people who
are listening hopefully, I hope.
We know that it is,
it is a discipline.
Not, you know, it's
not a friendly word
to many now but it is a discipline.
The discipline means that you
love it more than anything else.
>> Yeah and so you mentioned that
your other discipline that kind
of preceded storytelling
was children's writing,
was writing books for children.
How did you get started doing that?
>> You know I was very fortunate.
I went into a marvelous
little publishing house still
in Atlanta, wonderful.
I say 'little' in that
at the time it was small,
it's a fantastic house,
Peachtree Publishers.
And I told a story to
the editor over the phone
that would never work today.
And she said send it in
and then I was mortified
because I didn't have
a written version.
And I struggled and struggled and
struggled because I am also dyslexic
and eventually got
it down and sent it.
And it was, and it truly,
sometimes you just get a leg up.
That particular editor
liked that particular story.
That publishing house was
just going into picture books,
I mean really they had had one
when they first opened [inaudible]
for many, many years,
20 years they did none.
It was timing.
It was a lot of things.
Writing, I just, just
beginning to get
and the [inaudible] editor
I'm just starting to get it.
It's the same thing.
>> Well, you've done pretty
well with it [laughter].
>> Some days I think
and sometimes ah.
>> So and so I mean
the thing that kind
of brought you together
is this work for children,
that you as a children's
author and you as an educator.
So how did you start that career?
>> I am not in the
classroom anymore,
I'm actually training teachers to
you know become better teachers.
>> Right.
>> But it's funny because I,
at the beginning I didn't know
who Carmen Agra Deedy was.
>> You and most of the world but
my mother [multiple speakers].
>> My superintendent said oh my God,
now that we have this grant I
will bring my favorite author
to [inaudible] who is this woman.
She's a Cuban writer.
You should know who she is.
I said well.
>> She is Mexican.
>> Right.
>> Well.
>> So my superintendent put me
under assignment to make sure
that Carmen had everything she
needed during her visit so I sat
down and I brought work with
me because my plan was to sit
in the back of the audience and
just work while she was talking.
And I never, my work never got done.
It just, it stayed there.
I actually left with
her and it stayed there
because I was mesmerized
by Carmen's stories.
I fell in love.
>> Wow, so which books were
you presenting at that event?
Do you remember?
>> Well, I come as an author
but it's a shadowy business
the world of children's books.
Granted literally the granting
comes often as you come
as a children's author and I
talk to children about writing
and I show a couple of my books.
Who knows which one it
was at the time but I.
>> Then, we, I still remember.
You told the story of how
you fell in love with a book.
>> Oh no, that was the story.
>> That was the story.
>> What I do then is I have about
45 minutes, is I talk about writing
for about five and then
I say but I'm not going
to read you a story today which
of course most of the time,
still you hear ah or hee,
hee, hee or you hear I hate
that from some kid in the back.
And I said I'm going
to tell you a story.
And so I use the time
to tell stories.
Our children are not
getting stories this way.
They are not.
This is not how they're
consuming stories.
>> That's true.
>> Karla knows this, not, well it's
been a couple of years ago yeah
that I finished a story,
it was this one.
The kid, yes you do.
Fourth graders, I was
telling them a scary story.
>> Oh yes.
>> At the end of the story,
because they love scary stories,
appropriate, age appropriate scary
stories, it was really quiet.
The kid in the front row
goes, tell another one.
Tell another one.
And I realized this is how
they traffic in stories,
it's coming from their devices.
>> Yeah.
>> But they need carbon-based
life-force
so mostly that's what I do.
>> But I also think that it
has to do with the fact that,
at least the children I work with,
my children from poverty
whose parents have two jobs
and in our culture when you're a
little child you get to hear all
of those stories when
they're cleaning the beans
and when they're sitting
and drinking coffee,
there's no time to do that anymore.
And if you add that to the fact
that these parents are coming home
exhausted and all they want is just
to sit down and have a
moment to themselves.
Unfortunately that moment to
themselves skip the moments
for the children so those
children only get to hear,
you know, did you eat dinner?
Did you brush your teeth?
Did you do your homework, go to bed?
And I think that's such a pity.
[Multiple speakers] you can't
blame them, it's survival but.
>> But then, you know then
[inaudible] it was just
under what I'm hoping Karla
will continue because she is,
cover your ears and go la, la, la.
She really is just fabulous.
She's fabulous and
she's so authentic
and I've been doing this enough
years that you know in five seconds
if someone has an authentic voice.
And I was just, I was just.
I loved her from the
first and I knew
that not only whether she wanted
to go into revivalist storytelling,
if she wanted to just tell the
children, the children not just
in the Latin culture, in all our
children, need to hear our stories.
And people at home, anyone
who is watching this,
stories are like human
connective tissue, in the absence
of that we're going to
become more and more
like our machines and
less and less human.
And it is that very human part of
us that creates empathy, humanity,
compassion, things that are
so necessary in order to have
and create any kind of a peaceful
village, world, office, family.
And it sounds so grand but
it's, it really is true
that we need each other's stories.
>> I think at the moment that we
stop telling stories is the moment
that we stop realizing that
we're just like each other.
>> Yeah.
>> She has a different
name, a different accent
but we all have that aunt.
We all have that cousin.
We all have that crazy
[multiple speakers].
>> And that actually
gets me to something
that I thought was very
interesting in hearing your stories.
I mean the stories that you
told Karla were very Mexican
and rooted in the desert.
>> Yeah.
>> And rooted in the landscape
and yet you were able to identify
where those things were that
everyone in the room was going
to relate to and say well because
you know nobody's family is
like this or my, you
had that covered.
>> Because it's exactly the same.
>> Yeah, so but at first
was that, was that difficult
or did you know sort
of instinctively what
would be universal?
>> I think.
I think that when you're in this
world long enough it just takes you,
it takes you some time but then
you start realizing that the color
of the eyes may be different
and the hair looks different
but inside we all have
a little bit of that.
Does that make sense?
We all have a little bit of
the crazy and the compassion
and the love and I think that the
moment we become too politically
correct and we stop talking
about these things is the moment
where we start separating each other
instead of finding common ground.
So that's just [multiple speakers].
>> These things meaning.
>> Yeah.
>> The things that culturally
identifies because when we came in,
anyone listening to this particular
podcast will not know what precedes
it, that we were joking about that
we wouldn't need mics because we're
so loud and it was a
cultural asset and liability.
And somebody is going
to take offense,
I'm saying that because how
could you take a sweeping brush?
Because, there are things that
culturally tend to occur not
in every person in the culture.
I have three daughters.
My youngest daughter, every so
often will grab me by the throat
in a corner and just, how
am I part of this family?
She is the quiet one and she doesn't
know how she fits but she fits
because we're still her people.
And when we talk about,
anything about our families,
how we love food, does every
Latin person love food?
No. Does every Scottish person have
this particular trait or the other?
I think we become very nervous
about including those
sort of sidebars that.
We're sort of realizing
they are universal
because the Scottish hearth and the
Mexican [foreign language spoken]
and the and so forth, right?
>> Yeah.
>> They're actually,
they're the same place.
They're the same place because you
were putting your finger on it.
They're the moments that happen
between people that
we find universal.
It's you know, the cheap aunt.
I mean we all know her
or him or cousin but.
>> They all have different names
but it's exactly the same
person regardless, yeah.
>> And then I guess
the other question is
that you know it is interesting, at
first we did a little introduction
where we spoke about the fact
that Latin cultures are similar
in many ways but then they're
also, each culture is unique
and the landscape will be different.
>> The food.
>> The interaction with.
>> The customs.
>> Indigenous cultures and other
immigrant groups whether there's.
There were a lot of
Africans or not in that area.
So, how does that affect
your doing programs together,
the fact that there's a Mexican
side of it and a Cuban side?
>> I think that has to do with the
fact that we both are very aware
of the human side and that
takes over completely.
I mean before we came
here we barely made it
because we were too busy
laughing and comparing notes
and how do you say this in
your, you know, in Cuba?
And this is how you say it in
Mexico, but it's the same thing.
Like my mother would not allow me
to go out after I took a shower
because I might catch, Carmen
what's it called again?
>> [Foreign language spoken]
>> Yeah.
>> You might get it in the air.
How do you [multiple speakers].
How do you get the air?
>> The vapors.
>> [Foreign language spoken] is oh,
you have the same thing
[multiple speakers] so if you went
out [foreign language spoken]
that means what I'm going to do
and God only knew what
affliction could befall you.
[Foreign language spoken] you know
my cousin Pepe he went [foreign
language spoken].
>> Pneumonia right.
>> Pneumonia.
>> Ma, you can't get
pneumonia in 24 hours.
You are doubting your mother?
>> Are you calling me a liar?
And of course you back down.
You're like this is crazy talk.
This is, if it was anybody?
Do other cultures do this?
Of course they do.
I have a friend, very [inaudible].
Her grandmother, Russian, oh Irena
[phonetic] do not sit on marble.
It freeze ovaries.
>> We have the same thing but
I won't say it [laughter].
>> You won't say it,
okay [laughter].
>> My mom might listen
to this sometime.
>> No, you can't bathe in the,
you can't take go into the water
if you've [multiple speakers].
If you've eaten you have to
wait two hours until you can get
into the water because,
yeah you could get a cramp.
>> Right.
>> There are other
cultures that have that.
My mother, a step further,
you can't take a shower.
Ma [multiple speakers]
wait, no, no, no.
No, a bath maybe you could drown but
a shower, what's going to happen?
I mean seriously, you would just be
exceedingly clean as you lay there
with a cramp on, in your bathtub.
I tried to explain this to my
mother for years and [inaudible].
>> Yeah, you don't know everything
my daughter who reads okay.
There is knowledge that is older.
>> This is.
This is perverted knowledge.
Okay this is not correct.
>> So, would you not wait like until
you were starving and purple on lips
in the ocean because otherwise
you knew that the moment you came
out that was the end of the trip.
>> They fed you and if they
fed you, two more hours.
>> Yeah.
>> No fun at the beach.
>> And that was the end of the trip.
>> That was more than
he wanted to know.
Look at this poor man suffering.
>> It's great though.
Well, but I mean this is also,
I mean you know we are the
American Folklife Center and we talk
about folklore and collect that
and these are all the variations
in the same cultural story you know
so it's exactly what
we study so it's great.
>> And what you asked about, the
different, different cultures,
how do we feel on the stage?
I think it's really wonderful
because there are subtleties that,
you know it's a cultural
elephant in the living room right?
What we'll do, well how do
Cubans and Mexicans get along?
Because we have an image of who
Cubans are, I love these people.
They have hearts as big as all
Havana and they are hard-working
and they are kinder than
you can imagine and what
about the Mexican people?
I have known them to be
generous to a fault, familial,
loving and then there are
caricatures of both cultures
which is different than
finding certain things that crop
up in cultures that we all identify
with like we all like to eat
or we know, we have the crazy aunt.
When we get on the stage I think
that what happens or should happen
up there should not be
verbal, it should be de facto.
Here are these two women who
are great friends from cultures
that sometimes view
each other suspiciously.
Oh you, you know guys immigrated.
It wasn't just oh so legally under
the J.F.K. Cuban Refugee Act.
Aren't you precious?
You know and we had to crawl
through the desert you know.
What do you think of
that or we had to.
And so there is a tension that often
just doesn't get discussed and maybe
at some point when we hit the
stories when we want to do that,
right now we just like to go
up there and go [laughter].
>> But I think it also
has to do with trust.
I would follow this woman
to the end of the world.
>> Ditto, ditto.
>> To the end of the world
because I know that there's never,
that would be unkind that would come
out of her mouth neither
to my culture or myself.
And you have to know
that if you're going
to stand up and open yourself up.
And you have to trust that
the same way she's trusting
that the audience is going
to listen, is going to listen
without judgement and
it's not really
that it's listening
without judgement.
It's judgement but it's
not judgement towards you.
It's judgement towards how they see
that story relating to themselves
and most of the times that's
a really positive thing.
And at some point you have to
remember that you're doing it
because you love to do it.
>> And if you get on a
stage with somebody you have
to trust the person you're with.
I think you put a finger on it
because I feel equally with Karla.
She knows.
She's come to my home.
She knows my parents.
You know she knows my children and
not a lot of people know how I look
like when I wake up in the morning.
She's one of the privileged
ones, yes, yes.
>> She's looks [inaudible].
>> So, yeah and you know one
of the things that really comes
out in your performances or the
one that we just had is you know,
you had mentioned before
that in your family
or around the table sometimes it's a
competition for who is going to talk
but between the two of you each
one of you is promoting the other.
You're not promoting
yourself you know
and that's really very endearing
about your performances.
>> Well, that's what
happens when you're in love.
>> Well, there are all
kinds of love in the world.
>> Think of it this way okay,
I think that to me there's no
better complement to my craft
that the fact that I'm with her.
>> Oh ditto, I loved
being with Karla today.
It was so, it was interesting.
You know I'm completely
so loving doing this.
It's like 25 years of, and
it feels so comfortable
because this has never happened.
I'm speaking on a stage
with someone who knows
where my stories come from.
It doesn't matter that she's not
from Cuba, she knows the people
and she knows the taboos.
She knows there are certain things
like she said, there's
a trust manual.
There are certain things
she will never say
or I would never say even as a joke.
>> Yeah.
>> Culturally about the other
because we know what a tender place
or a wounding place that could be.
And we both like to be irreverent.
We love being irreverent, it's
what makes stories really powerful
because it's that irreverence
and it's the laughter that opens
up the solar plexus
so that truth gets in.
That's why some of the greats,
to me the most wonderful
storytellers are the ones I truly
love note just how much humor
to use so that people relax
and then you can come
in with something that's a
little more profound maybe
but not necessarily
from you but a truth
that you learned the hard
way that you can share.
Does that make sense?
>> But I think it also has
to do with the fact that,
and I'm making an assumption
here, we both have.
We both come from cultures
that have faced a lot of pain
and that has understood from
the longest time that it has
to be dealt with laughter.
>> We had this conversation
didn't we?
>> Yeah, yeah.
>> That both of us have cultures
that for different reasons
have suffered a great deal,
at least culturally that's how.
It's the message that's sent down
and that the only way to deal
with this place you're in, you
know, a citizen, non-citizen,
a refugee with some
standing but with often scorn
because people don't understand
the history of the people that went
through this and actually how
many of them were so democratic
in their views and kind
but, and so we laugh.
We laugh. We laugh.
We laugh. One of my favorite stories
I can't share today but it was
from a relative, someone
we knew on the outskirts
of our life had passed away,
a very unpleasant person.
And everyone was saying all these
lovely things as you do and one
of my aunts [inaudible]
and goes, you know,
there are some people
you just cannot
like until they're dead [laughter].
[Inaudible] and I, so who's laughing
in the funeral home
right, not her, me and I'm.
But it's that moment of
wickedness and laughter
and we call it [foreign
language spoken]
which is spark and that is based.
>> You have to have it.
>> Well, it's the comedy/tragedy
mask.
>> Yeah.
>> It's very much based
in and sometimes
in a certain amount
of generational pain.
>> Yeah.
>> And you have, you have to have
it because what's the alternative?
>> [Foreign language spoken] oh I'm
sorry, in Cuba we say [inaudible]
that we laugh until we cry
and we cry until we laugh.
It's beautiful, there you go.
>> Yeah I notice Karla
your stories all kind
of push the boundaries with the.
>> I was extremely nervous.
>> The funeral that
wasn't a funeral.
>> There wasn't really a funeral.
>> And the, and the, yeah and
the, you know the pyromaniac.
>> The pyromaniac mother that
wasn't really a pyromaniac.
>> Yeah, so what reactions have
you gotten to those stories?
I mean really they are very funny
but also pushing those boundaries.
>> This is why I make Carmen well,
give the disclaimer because I know.
I mean we're talking
about a woman who is ready
to burn a house down you know, it's.
I don't know how I haven't been,
I don't know if that's the proper
expression, but haven't been burned
at the stake before, the
stake, the stake, just burned.
>> There you go.
You know my family has such
finesse when telling the stories
because there are kids around.
They just, it just happens you
know and it has to do with the fact
that 'in for a penny,
in for a pound'.
Either you do it or you
don't and you have to trust
that the people will have the
same sense of humor that you do.
Maybe that's the reason
why they're there
and you just have to
lay it out there.
Just, it's you open.
>> Right.
>> And then it happens.
>> Well I mean that detail
about moving the geraniums
or they will get burned
is just so precious and.
>> Really right?
>> And solely.
>> And to me that's
who my grandmother was.
It's like, you know you pay
attention to love and to embracing
and for this woman to be
this angry that she was ready
to burn this most sacred
place for somebody,
that's how much in pain she was.
I'm happy she didn't.
>> If she intended
to do it ever at all.
>> I don't think she ever did.
I think she just.
I think it was a great
sweeping gesture.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> Yeah. So, again yeah so I
mean I think that that really,
it's impressive that the
story walks that fine line
between what would really disturb
people and yet it just comes
out being funny like you say.
>> I certainly hope nobody came
out of there thinking, you know,
oh my God that was horrible.
What was this woman thinking?
>> It was wonderful.
>> No, I think it was
great, yeah, yeah, so.
>> And sometimes a
disclaimer is what you need.
>> Yeah.
>> The story sometimes
needs a little paving
and whether someone does it or
you do it for yourself because all
of us, you know, the best stories
do push the boundaries a little
but you have to look
at your audience.
You may come in with a story
that you are ready to tell
and then you look at
the demographics
or you look at what's happening.
There's been a 30-minute delay,
people are tired, whatever
and you have to make an
assessment at that moment
and be absolutely willing
to kill your darling,
just like when you're writing.
>> Yeah.
>> And say I can't do this
today or say I'm going for it
but letting the audience know,
just so you know this
story will end well.
Remember that before we begin right
and that thing where we both talked
to the audience to me is very much a
part of the old traditional telling
that has survived with
a lot of the best of us
that tell the stories now
publicly that we only told at home.
And I love that.
I love including the audience.
>> Yeah.
>> I think it's impossible to tell a
story without including the audience
because it's our story now.
>> But they don't know
how to respond anymore
because once they did and now.
>> Once it was more common yeah.
>> It was more common.
>> Yeah.
>> Now the people have been trained
to observe whether it's a screen
or even in a theater production
or an opera, you are not.
You don't [inaudible]
that fourth wall.
And story is the wicked
child in the family.
>> So what about your
story about your father?
That also had that moment
when you thought, okay,
he's going to throw rocks at
this man and you know [laughter]
and there's [multiple
speakers] assault.
>> Oh, I didn't tell you the
one about my father pissing
in the woods, that's
another one but now.
>> And yet it, you know, the
unexpected happens in that story
and brings about this
transformation.
>> That was a true story so
part of it was a true story
but even a true story takes
craft because we all know
that we could all be at the
same place at the same time,
have something happen
and everyone is going
to put a slightly different
narrative.
But how do you get a narrative
that's cohesive, one that works?
And that takes time, craft
and multiple tellings.
In this case it was my father's
story and it took going back
to him several times and to say,
you know, what about this moment?
And I, you know, this is
not in the story but I said,
so were you really going
to pelt [inaudible]?
I had every intention of pelting
that man with rocks because he was
so hurt and angry and I said, and?
He said [inaudible].
It was divine intervention which is,
you know I'd like to think
it was divine intervention
because my father learning to read
meant that my sister and I grew
up in a home filled with books
and periodicals and magazines and,
which meant our children were part
of the weekly reader book club
which meant my grandchildren
are growing
up book-drunk and look at that.
Look at that, one totally
ill-tempered man,
a one and you know I'd would an
irascible man, an unpleasant man
that has no surname in our family,
San Antonio, changed generations
and generations by
teaching my father to read.
>> But I think it was also you know,
it could have been
divine intervention
but there was also the
intervention of your father's heart
because you could throw a rock at
a man who was awake so the fact
that it woke him up didn't
really stop [laughter].
>> No, it threw him off and Antonio
so quickly coming in with it.
What are you doing here?
Why can't you read?
And you know, in the story
and I talked to my dad
because of course I have to create,
you have to create a certain amount
of dialogue even in memory,
my father cannot have a
perfect memory of what happened.
Even him, in that sort of "Road to
Damascus" moment was not something
that he could tell you, oh I
remember the entire the narrative.
He's 92 today, you know like
not today but at this moment
but he can tell me the meat
of it and certain things will,
are very clear in his mind.
He doesn't remember being asked
but he remembers those
two words [inaudible].
Oh in Spanish it's one word.
>> Yeah.
>> Which is 'teach me'
>> To me that's the.
>> But don't you find that one
of the hardest things to do
when you're telling a story is
telling somebody else's story
especially when they're your family,
especially when you
want to honor it?
Because it's, if it's your story
you can make it however you want to
but if it's somebody else's story
and it's that important to them
that they told it to you
and you're going to tell it
to an audience, it's just.
You want to tell the story
because it's funny but you want
to tell the story because
it's important too
and to honor the way it meant to be.
It's hard.
>> This one is unusual.
I tell lots of stories
about my family
but in nearly every story I
am present so that it's part.
It's mostly memory
and then interviews
and then created the story.
With this one of course
I was not present,
not even the glint in my papa's eye.
So it was a, I didn't
tell this until about two,
three years ago because it was.
It was a hard story.
It was a story I wasn't sure
he was ready to have me tell.
And there are certain
stories you do ask permission.
>> Yeah.
>> Before you tell publicly because
you chose to be a public person
but not everyone in
your life chose that.
And then other stories, you know, I,
depending on them mostly
I would tell the family,
right you remember this story
about you know how mommy
or the [inaudible] did this?
I'm working on that story so if you
have any memories you want to share?
And of course one of
the aunts will call.
Do not listen to Hilda
[assumed spelling].
She never only remembers
things right but I was there.
>> I am your [inaudible].
>> Yeah. That's not how it happened.
>> [Foreign language
spoken] you don't remember.
That's true.
>> So you get that in your
family as well [inaudible]?
>> I'm the one that talks the least.
My mom always said,
you sit and you listen.
And then I just open.
There's a story I'm still working
on about an elephant that was left
in my grandfather's [inaudible].
What is an elephant doing in
the middle of the district?
I don't know.
I'm still working on it.
But it's a story that was told and
all I have to do is to put food
on the table or beans to be cleaned
and put coffee and I seat my tias
around and I just grab a notebook
and listen, that's all I have to do.
Because I know they're
not going to let me talk.
I'm not going to get it right
so they start interrupting
each other, yeah.
>> And that's when
we get great stories.
>> Yeah.
>> But that generation
is disappearing.
>> Yeah.
>> We look at.
We're the ones collecting now
these stories from our families
and those people are still talking.
We'll likely still be talking
but even our own children,
it's already changing.
Although my girls you know
tell wonderful stories
but they've been steeped in them.
But most young people are not.
See the reason listening
is so important is
because it's how you learn tempo,
tone, rhythm, the important pause,
there's such a thing as,
there's not just the wrong word.
There is not just 'the' word.
There is the 'right' word.
The right word makes
all the difference.
And that is only learned
by listening and listening
and listening to the people
you love to hear tell stories.
Slowly you start to see patterns,
see patterns in how they crescendo,
how they slow a story
down or how they say,
and once again he said no I won't.
And then he comes again, once again,
and now the audience starts to say,
no I won't, so that there's a
call, a natural call and response,
all that happens, yeah and but
what's going to happen in 15,
20, 30,40 years you know?
The stories are changing certainly.
>> Yeah, you think
technology is part of that?
>> You're going to have time
for this conversation, okay.
I didn't say [inaudible] recently.
>> Oh, so I was wondering what your
[multiple speakers] was about, yeah.
>> That was the, well
the first one was.
It was just a story but
the "TED" talk from 2005.
But the TEDx talk was about
how important it would,
you know stories.
Do they matter?
Will they still be around?
And I do believe they
will be but the,
I guess to me the most
important issue was,
will we know how to
listen any longer?
Or will we be so inattentive
to another human being
because it requires
frontal lobe concentration
and that's just primal
[inaudible] that we will be able
to follow narrative in
the traditional sense.
I mean I don't know the answer
but I think it'll only happen
if what began as a revival some 40
or 50 years ago in storytelling,
in revivalist North
American storytelling.
And it sort of spread throughout the
world in little pockets continuously
but this is not storytelling
the way it happened organically.
It's still something created, like
a perfect reproduction of you know,
a consul from you know
the 16th century,
whatever [foreign language
spoken] and it's just.
It's going to be really close but
close [inaudible] still talking.
>> Yeah.
>> And we are doing
our part or trying.
>> And so I had one other sort
of specific question for you.
You had mentioned that some of
your family stories or your stories
about growing up were
collected after you were on NPR
for quite a while doing stories
about [multiple speakers].
>> Weekend edition of "All
Things Considered" yeah.
>> How did that come about?
>> Oh my God, because
life is so weird.
I was hit head on at a light
and my car was totalled
and my knee was shattered.
This is actually part of the answer
which is a very short answer.
And it took me some time to recover
and I was very anxious
about driving.
I have a really good learning
curve when it comes to pain.
So whew and I had a phone
call from my then manager,
Robin DeFoe [phonetic]
this wonderful woman,
and she said this radio
station called NPR, NRP, NPR.
I said, NPR, NPR?
This was like, I don't know
this had to be like 1991,
92, 93 something like that.
I don't remember.
Right in there and she
said they want you to come
and tell some stories because
they heard you tell something
on you know Peach Radio,
Atlanta radio.
Georgia, it was Georgia public
television, ah Georgia radio.
And I had to drive to do it
and that's how it happened.
I almost cancelled because I
was so terrified and I just,
this is going to sound crazy.
But it used to make me insane,
my mother would say, I did not
and your father did
not leave our country,
our beloved country and come here.
We did not leave Communist Cuba
so that you would be too afraid
to take one step after the other
because I was a timid girl.
I could hear her nagging in my head
and I got in the car and I drove
down to the little studio
in Georgia and I went
like an old woman [inaudible]
down the road, got there
and taped the first of what became,
I don't know, several dozen stories.
And 12 of them ended
up on a collection
but it was, that's how it happened.
It was just sort of a.
It was a sweet time.
>> Yeah, so that was kind of
early in your career right?
>> Yes, it was.
It was. And it was trial
by fire, it really was.
I had no idea, as everything in
life, no idea what I was doing.
>> So I guess, you know,
Carmen your stories
and writing are what you've been
doing professionally for a long time
but for Karla it, you know,
you have another profession.
>> Very new, yeah.
>> And it's new to you, so what
are your plans for the future
as far as these stories go?
>> Oh gosh, this is
something I love.
I like teaching.
I love my children.
I love my colleagues.
I've been teaching for 16, 20 years.
I refuse to give the exact amount
because then I'm going
to have to date myself.
This is, that is my life
and this is my passion.
So as long as I can continue
to do it and there's a public
that allows me to open my mouth
in front of them I'll do it.
How is it going to happen?
I don't know.
>> It's happening already.
Yeah, I think she's going to be
a very important, my prediction,
a very important voice in the
Mexican/American community of story
and of narrative and outside
of that into the greater sort
of American storytelling community.
She has. She's the real thing.
>> Well, I think we can say
you're both the real thing
and you're both going to
be very important voices
and you both are very
important voices
so we thank you very
much for this interview.
>> [Inaudible] thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> And for our program
earlier today.
Thank you so much.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.